[MUSIC]
Welcome, my name is Wil Torres.
This is application week,
connecting the dots.
Each day this week, we've been focusing
on different pieces of the application.
And so, we navigate it through
what are the different parts,
we talked about testing,
transcripts, academics.
Yesterday, we talked a lot about letters
of recommendation in reference to both
folks applying, as well as recommenders.
Today, we're going to
put those dots together.
And I'm really excited about this
because one of the things that
I learned over my career as
an admissions professional is that no
single part of the application like,
they all belong together.
Together, they are the things that
help us really understand who you are.
So it's not about the dots specifically,
but what is that picture,
what is that constellation, if you
think about those dots as stars, right,
each one of those sections is an area for
you to shine.
What is the constellation that
is drawn when we step back and
look at all of those pieces together?
And so I'm joined today, we are going to
start with panels introductions.
I'm so excited.
I don't really get to do a lot
of panels with Stephanie, so
you can tell us where my energy is.
We'll talk about
the holistic review process.
Then we'll start with a moderated Q and
A and then we'll turn to the Q and A box.
We'll be infusing your
questions all the way through.
So if you see questions that you
are particularly inspired by or
that resonate with you, go ahead and
click that thumbs up button,
that will vote that question and
help it get to the top of the list.
All right, so with that, Stephanie.
>> Yes.
>> Brief introduction, and
what is one of your life goals?
>> [LAUGH] putting me on the spot.
Well, welcome everybody.
My name is Stephanie Witlin.
I am one of the admissions officers at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
And I'm delighted today to
join Wil in this session.
Wil, I love how you described
it as a constellation.
I made note of that because it very
much does describe how each element is
intertwined and how together,
it creates something, so I love that.
[COUGH] One of my life goals,
well, I have a son now.
He's eight.
So I've had him for a few years,
[LAUGH] but I think for
me, I've always been a curious person and
someone who seeks to understand, and
my life goal is to make sure that he and
myself are able to explore and
learn more about the world.
And I think that's really important from
a perspective of a child growing up, and
exploring, and being curious, and
being aware, and being open minded so.
>> Okay, my heart just kind
of exploded for a little bit.
That is such a heartfelt and
authentic response to that answer and it
just kind of, yes, I am feeling that I'm
here to support you all the way through.
And so as we go through like
think about your dreams,
think about your life goals for everybody
out there, think about a dream big,
and how can business school
help you reach those dreams?
When I think that's one of those things
that I like to encourage folks to think
about, your career infuses so
much of who you are.
So it's things about curiosity,
who are the people in your life?
It might be your son, right?
And how are you going to live a meaningful
constructive life that when you look back
on, you can be proud of?
And so
if business school is part of that path,
we are here to help guide you along it.
And so just to set a little bit of
a foundation about what we're going to
cover, it's going to be both at that
high level and we'll go ahead and
dig into the little bits.
So at the GSB, we're looking for
things in three general buckets,
intellectual vitality,
demonstrated leadership potential, and
personal qualities and contributions.
These are background agnostic, meaning
that we find them anywhere in your life
from all different walks of life,
any career, kind of school background.
There are so many ways to show these three
qualities and different types of qualities
within them, and we celebrate and
recognize wherever they come up for you.
They are also context-dependent.
So we know if you are earlier
in your career versus later,
there's going to be a different set
of opportunities, and that's normal.
And we're taking that into account
as we're reading your application.
Your application consists of
a bunch of different sections,
these stars that I referred to earlier.
And it's through these that we
get that picture of who you are.
Yes, it's an imperfect
picture because you are so
much more than what's going to
be contained on those pages.
But through this application,
we're trying to understand who you are,
how you're going to show up in our
classrooms and in our community.
So with that, I'm going to stop sharing.
And then Stephanie,
we are going to spend a good amount of
time just talking about the application.
So from where you sit,
what does a strong application look like?
>> Well, there is no one formula for
what strong looks like.
And certainly, for
us who are evaluating candidates,
we are taking a holistic approach,
which is why this is a great
session on connecting the dots.
It's being able to see evidence throughout
the application where there is parts
that sort of sparkle or show up in terms
of someone's impact that they've had or
the ways in which they've
been intellectually engaged.
So it's not a specific thing and I think
that's what makes it so hard to explain.
But we certainly more than anything
are looking to learn about you.
So strong applications are those people or
those candidates who can really
convey who they are as a person,
and what they've done,
and then concise way and
use all parts of the application
to demonstrate those qualities.
>> Yeah, I love, you mentioned
evidence at the beginning and
I think that's one of
those pieces that if you
think about that analogy of that
picture that I just showed earlier,
where each part of the application was
a different part of a greater picture,
it's those evidence pieces that really
adds clarity and definition to those
sections and helps us understand, okay,
this is how this pieces together.
Would you say that like kind
of resonates with that sound?
>> Yeah, actually, I'll use an example
because I think people are so
focused on, they see one of our
criterias intellectual vitality,
and you may initially drive to,
that means they're looking at my GMAT and
my GRE or GPAs.
So all of that, so
whether it was a test score or GPA.
And while that certainly is
part of intellectual vitality.
As someone who's evaluating applications,
I'm looking for it all over the place.
And a great example is like, it could come
up in a letter of recommendation where
the recommender is indicating that
this particular individual saw
a need to develop a new tool That
would help improve a system or
project and
as a result they then taught others.
But they learned it on their own and then
they applied it to what they were doing.
And if that isn't intellectual vitality,
I don't know what is.
So it's like you're looking for
places where you see someone who's just
intellectually curious, who is engaged.
They have a willingness to learn.
They want to share
[INAUDIBLE] with others.
And I think it is so
much more than just a GPA or a test score.
And so I want people to really understand
that as we read that, I see that,
and I'm like, wow, that's strong evidence
of someone's intellectual vitality.
They took something above and
beyond and then they grew it.
And being able to really see that
curiosity come through is fascinating, so.
>> Yeah, look so all these things
could come up in different ways.
Are there any unexpected places as well?
You gave one example for us to think
broadly about where things could come up.
I know, sometimes kind of staying on
the theme of intellectual vitality.
I've seen it come up in
the background question,
where we're asking about a time in the
last few years where your background has
influenced your
participation in something.
And sometimes even the way folks
engaged with who they are,
that level of self awareness and
connection to the world around them,
there is a level of intellectual
vitality there as well.
There's so many types of intellect.
>> [COUGH]
>> Emotional intelligence,
people intelligence, tactical.
Sometimes people are really
good in visualizing things.
So I think there's so
many different ways to show even
different types of intelligence.
>> Yeah.
>> And so
just lean into the things that
feel natural and resonate for you.
>> Yeah.
>> That's my thing.
>> Yeah, I mean overarching while we've
already kind of addressed the question,
a strong application is just really
going to convey who you are, right?
And so to the extent that you can do that,
you're putting your best foot forward.
So we want to see all
elements of you as a person.
>> Yeah.
So your perfect segue, and folks in
the Q&A box are already beating me to
that next question that I wanted
us to unpack a little bit.
So I've been using the analogy
of here's a bigger picture.
And the application shows different parts,
we use the example of a constellation
with different stars.
And so there's also a number of questions
about, do these have to connect?
Do I have to make sure things resonate
across or can things be standalone?
Let's go there.
Let's talk about how do we think about
the sections in concert with each other?
Because even the theme of today's
panel is connecting the dots.
So-
>> Right.
>> Any thoughts that you have,
let's go there.
>> I don't think it needs
to be as perfectly woven
together as you think it may.
There might be elements of your life that
are an important piece of who you are but
don't necessarily show up in other places.
I think there certainly wants to
be I want to see a theme of what's
important to you, what you value, and
I imagine that those are going to
show up in different ways
throughout the application.
I'm trying to think if
there's anything else I can
sort of convey as it
relates to describing.
So for example, you said before there
might be something in the background and
perspective that gives us some idea
about how the life they've lived and
the experiences they've had.
Have impacted the way that
they view the world or
even how they present in the workplace.
And we might see some
small evidence of that.
And then also notice that a recommender or
in your LORs,
or even in your essays that
you elaborate more on that and
that that becomes another piece of who
you are and we get to see that elsewhere.
But I don't think we're necessarily
looking to make that tie a bow.
I think everyone is so
multifaceted taking all the components and
then building the picture of who you are.
And you may be a different person
in different contexts, and
bring different things to different
communities that you're involved with.
>> Yeah, sorry.
My eyes just lit up as you were talking
about how you might live in different
communities, be a different individual,
knowing that for many folks,
there might be some
element of code switching.
Where maybe the language or the presence,
you might show up differently
at work than you do at home.
But that doesn't mean,
that's still you, right?
Those are still elements and and
manifestations of who you are.
So even if, and I've learned
this over time, too, it's like,
even if things might seem like disjointed,
you as an individual,
because you're the one going through them,
they are connected.
And so I wouldn't have anybody out there
feel worried that things don't always seem
like, as you said,
tied into a perfect bow.
But really, as you dig deeper and
think about,
okay, you as an individual, as you
center yourself, you are the connector.
So what is it about you that's
bringing those things together?
because at some level, yeah,
they're going to be connected through you.
So I think that's one of those things.
[COUGH]
>> I think being able to look at yourself
as more than the one dimensional
paper [INAUDIBLE] screen that you're,
I think we all are aware that individuals,
human beings are complex.
And so there's so many different facets
that we're going to learn about.
And I think that's what makes
our application so robust and
that we give candidates
the opportunity to demonstrate all of
those in many different
places on the application.
>> All right, so
there's a question in the Q&A box that
>> [COUGH]
>> Has 3 X the number of upvotes
>> Okay,
>> As any other question.
So let's go there because also,
I'm a big fan of starting with,
here's things to watch out for, and
then here's how to address them.
So maybe if we can start with like, what
were in any examples that we've seen of
definite like quote unquote, not to dos.
Or as I like to think of them, areas
of opportunity, and then, afterwards,
we can talk about like, all right, now
let's how to beef things like that up, so.
[LAUGH].
Any red flags for you.
>> I mean, the most obvious not to do or
definite not to do is to not
answer [LAUGH] The questions
that we ask of you, right?
We literally do want you
to take the time and
answer the prompts that
we have provided for you.
There's reason and
meaning behind what we ask and so
we're trying to capture that information.
I mean, at an overarching just
following instructions and
really putting your best foot forward and
really answering the prompts
as they're provided.
>> Yeah, there's been times I read essays,
and I'd finish them like,
I actually don't know what matters to you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And so that [LAUGH] I think that's
like, for me the epitome of
what you're saying right now.
There's this other level of that too,
not just that question and prompt itself,
but as you look at the application,
every blank spot's an opportunity.
Optional, yes,
that doesn't mean you have to use it.
But when we're asking you in your
employment or work history section,
information about those roles Sometimes I
see people leave those blank and
then the application
itself looks very sparse.
And there's not enough meet in
the resume to help cover that.
So, as you're thinking about both,
like every element as a different
angle on who you are,
I think that's one of those not complete,
like red flags.
But something for you to think about
as you're doing this like just that
completeness and effort element.
>> I'm glad you brought that up,
we asked folks to submit a resume but
there's also the employment section and
we ask people to fill that out.
And it is if you see what I would
say is a thinner application
where some of those places
are not filled out,
it does beg the question of
the amount of effort you put into it.
Because certainly while we can see
what you've done on your resume,
we provide those other places
on the application for
you to really articulate
things more clearly.
And it's helpful to us we don't
ask it just to fill the space,
we genuinely have a desire and
understanding and
so, be sure that you are putting
your best foot forward.
And not giving us any instance
where we have to think,
what kind of effort or
commitment did they have to this process?
>> Yeah, outside of the optional questions
because those are optional like truly-
>> Yes, of course, right.
>> We've been meeting people who have
filled all of them out with admitted
people who have left them all blank so
know that truly optional.
>> And I think that's one of
the questions that comes up at probably I
thought that might be the top line
question would have to answer.
So yes let me first please reiterate that,
if we say it is optional it is
genuinely optional and we only want
you to include something if you feel
like it's compelling, that it provides
you with another opportunity.
To share something that you may not have
been able to communicate elsewhere in
the application.
But we absolutely do not look or
put anyone at a disadvantage.
If, for instance,
I do not fill out the optional impact
questions where those short answers.
>> So, I could not have planted
a better [LAUGH] segue for
the next top question here.
We're talking a lot about
connecting the dots.
Here is some optional spaces.
So and I think it works
perfectly with today's topic.
So, this is a question from Huggy Rao.
How do you see successful
applicants use the optional essays?
Do they answer all of them present to
provide as many pieces as possible or
answer fewer to better highlight
the important aspects?
When might be a time to use
those impact questions?
Let's shed some light there.
>> Yeah, there's so
many ways that they can be used and
I've seen it done in many ways and
there's no one right way to do it.
Oftentimes the impact prompts
can be a great opportunity for
you to elaborate on
a particular extracurricular or
activity or community organization
you are a part of and
to talk a little bit about
maybe the impact you had.
And again, I want people to
understand that the impact
doesn't have to be at a large scale.
It can also be the impact you've had
with a mentee or as you were tutoring or
coaching one individual and help support
that person as they were navigating there,
either their educational journey or
even career journey.
So, I see the impact essays as
a nice way to elaborate on some
of the things you have done and
maybe have not glossed over but
we're able to elaborate as much
on our part in the application.
It's also nice to see there might be
something on your resume that you've
indicated that you're really proud
of because it was a big success or
accomplishment.
And then to be able to take one piece or
component of that and
really give us a little bit more meat.
So, it's all about getting evidence.
So, we are evidence based in
terms of how we evaluate.
We want to see what you've done.
And I do believe that the impact
prompts give us that opportunity
to step a little bit smaller.
They're like snippets,
it's not something that you necessarily
need to incorporate into an essay but
they can be small vignettes of
ways in which, and most impactful.
>> I'm about to start
using small vignettes.
>> I just give up.
>> I love that.
Yeah because like you're
saying your resume says what?
Right, oftentimes that's how
the resume is structured.
Like, this is what I did.
This is what I did.
But that often misses we don't have
enough space to talk about the how.
>> Right?
>> If you're thinking about some of
those leadership competencies..
How did you get that thing to happen?
What was the ripple effect?
Or why was it significant for
that person or organization or place?
And sometimes that next step
of helping us understand,
what did your footprint look like?
You don't necessarily have
that same space in a resume.
I would also say sometimes in the essays,
right,
sometimes you may refer to something.
>> Yeah.
But Stephanie, do you remember
work-shopping the wording for
these optional questions?
>> [LAUGH] Yes
>> Like,
how precise we were trying to
be to make sure it was clear.
I think for the folks out there, even
letting you know what the historical like
how these questions were born might be
helpful and how to understand them.
So in the past, so
we've had the what matters most to you and
why essay for a really long time.
And overtime, we're finding that people
were trying to put accomplishments.
>> All accomplishments they
were stuffing accomplishments.
>> Yeah, and
it was definitely being proud of and
we definitely want to learn about them.
But it didn't always fit with the flow of
what they were talking about as mattering
or it made essays seem like here's what
matters and here's evidence versus
>> Yes.
>> The why?
>> Let me explain why.
And while it is important for
you to explain why something matters,
it doesn't need to be like I did X,
Y and Z and that's why.
[LAUGH]
>> So,
that's where the, the genesis of these
optional questions came into play.
This allows you to both answer kind of
to the fullest and however you want in
any of those other spaces, and then
still have dedicated space to allow that
give us those kind of how, why,
what of the accomplishments you've had.
And that's why there's three as well, like
they don't always have to be connected.
Sometimes accomplishments come in
many different parts of your life.
There doesn't even have to be a references
of anywhere else in the application.
Each of those can be standalone, or
they can be used to kind of
give more depth somewhere else.
So-
>> Yeah.
>> That is a very long winded way of
saying use it in a way that feels right
for you.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah, and
I like I think it is important
to reiterate that what we
genuinely are looking for and
know what matters most and
why is to find out who you are as a person
and what is most meaningful for you.
And we want you to go deep in a way that
allows you to share those reasons and
we want you to take maybe some of this
other stuff, which you may have put in
there because you felt like you
still wanted to share those stories,
which we value as well.
But now you have another
space to put those and so
that's the intent the impact essay or
the impact short answers,
and I would say that as well
shared like they don't have to be.
Be intertwined,
they can be three disparate and
that's probably typical I would even say.
Don't try to fill the space if you don't
genuinely have something significant
to share you may have already
conveyed what you needed to.
You can do to strong, you could have
one strong one that really speaks to
a way in which you've been impactful.
So we don't want you to water down but
also trying to just give ourselves three.
If you feel that you can share impact more
succinctly in one or two, so
>> I'm loving this
I'm loving these questions in the Q&A box,
so
we're already like,
>> Deviating from our script, [LAUGH]
>> This is way more way more fun.
So someone is asking about how do
we convey intellectual vitality and
leadership in what matters most?
There's going to be some
myth busting here and
I think that's why this
one made me light up.
Alumns have said this essay must
be from somewhere heartfelt and
vulnerable, I wonder how to talk
about intellect and leadership here.
I think this is such a fascinating
question because you're understanding
both hey, what are the things
that the GSB is looking for?
How can I be thoughtful
about what I'm writing?
And like, how do I balance
like all of the advice and
different things that I'm hearing and
of course, that myth busting element.
So Stephany, let's talk a little
bit about the essays right,
how do they fit in with the greater
picture of application?
What makes a quote unquote well, let's say
helpful essay as opposed to a good or bad.
because even shifting our mind frame about
how we use the essays might help people
feel more comfortable with
what they're writing.
And then let's unpack this,
like the necessity of being heartfelt and
vulnerable, like that has a lot,
>> That's heavy yeah, that's deep.
We want you to be introspective,
we want to hear your authentic voice.
So those things are important,
the best way to describe the essay and
how it can most effectively
convey who you are.
Is to have someone who knows you really,
really well read your essay and
make sure it sounds like you and
authentically you.
Not that necessarily has to be vulnerable,
you do not have to,
we do those talk sessions, and if there's
anything I've learned from the talk.
And for those of you on
the line if you're unaware,
this is a really sort of a GSB
tradition of students sharing a story.
With their classmates that might
also be very heartfelt and
vulnerable that's where you're starting
to see those elements come in.
And I have heard them say
in the coaching of that
you can share as much as
you're comfortable with.
Without going to a level
that puts you in a position
that really can be difficult for you.
Right, so it's about understanding
the learning part or
stepping up from what you
learn from the experience.
So I guess as I see this,
I want you to be authentic,
I want to see your authentic voice.
And be genuine about it, who it is and
it should speak to you but
you don't have to feel like you have to.
Your heart has to bleed to
get something on the paper
that's going to be as you said,
helpful for us.
>> Yeah.
>> I don't know how to share that, that
it's it might be a really funny thing,
might be something that's like
just really fun and important.
But it is who you are as a person, right
and so that I feel like needs to be part.
It does not have to be this like I
found myself in the depths of so
[LAUGH] I don't know how to describe but
it's how do you want to say that?
Well, I know you've seen
some of these essays too,
I don't know they come in all
different shapes and colors.
>> Exactly that heartfelt piece,
like you said, that's you, right?
Talking about the things that
are important to you, that piece and
then the vulnerable element,
I define that very broadly.
Being vulnerable means sharing can
be mean sharing something that's
meaningful for you.
Sometimes it's the things
that you care the most about.
That's when you feel the most vulnerable
when you're putting it out there because
you don't know how the world may or
may not kind of react to it.
And so I would say don't
always think vulnerable as
a place of fear or
something you're hiding but
vulnerable in sharing something
that's important to you.
And that can be a realization
from something more personal or
it can be something that you
talk about everyday, right.
It's that feeling that
you have connected to it.
And then in terms of
the intellectual vitality and
leadership I don't think you need
to strategize too much about it.
That question in particular is more
about that self reflection element,
De Moth talks a lot about
the body of research.
That say some of the most successful
leaders are the ones who lead
from a place of mission and values.
And this is a way for
you to start discovering those and
letting us know what are some of yours and
what are some of your motivations?
>> Yeah, it's a very good point,
I do think it is something I used to
share when I would be on the road that,
[COUGH] If you do your essay well.
Or if you really spend the time to focus
on it, it is likely something that's so
core to the person that
you are to you as a being.
That it's a theme that resonates
throughout your life and
this individual mentioned that
they had heard from alums.
And what I do hear from alums and
students is that if done well,
it's the kind of essay that if
you read it 10 years post GSB.
The common denominator that
theme still resonates for
the person that you are, right?
And it's the way that you make decisions
whether you know it or not, right?
So when faced with a decision where
you can go in two directions,
your core is what makes you decide
to go one way or the other.
And those are the kind of things that
we hope to kind of hear about whatever
that might be for you.
But the thing that follows
you throughout your life and
is the essence of the person that you are.
>> Yeah, I've heard of alums who,
when faced with life choices,
maybe it's career maybe like,
they've gone back to that essay.
>> Yes.
>> What was driving me was the resume,
it's like how am I going to
use that going forward?
>> Yeah.
>> I'm not going to lie [LAUGH] I use it
as I was writing cover letters to be like,
this is why I'm making this decision, so,
>> Yeah.
>> Even beyond the application [LAUGH]
what you learned from this question,
>> Right,
it's like an almost every decision,
for me as I shared previously,
this value of curiosity and
wanting to learn and explore like.
When faced with a decision, I'm always
going to try to go with the like let's
go out and see that or travel and
understand and just be more curious.
So that too is all about, yeah.
>> Yeah and a couple more questions while
we're still on this topic of essays and
then we will get around to a couple others
from different parts of the application.
There's a question here from
Chieffing about like How do you feel
when you read a great,
what matters most essay?
What are some of the things that
make those standout to you?
>> Well, I think it is when I feel
like I'm at the end of the essay
that I can say to myself, okay,
I understand a little bit
more who this person is now,
this is your application.
This by no means demonstrates
the person you are, [LAUGH] there's so
much more to you than what you
can put in the application.
But it gives us a piece and a little bit
of a window into who you are as a person.
So that's a very vague way to answer but
for me that's,
if I come out of that knowing,
okay, now I get.
because I think the rest of
the application really does give you
an opportunity to describe what you've
done and the impact that you've had.
Things that definitely you've
had some control of and
then this allows you to really
elaborate on you as a person.
So,
>> Yeah, I think that's how,
even if you're writing the same
thing as a ton of other people,
when it's your interpretation of it and
its effect on you and
who you are,
that immediately sets it apart.
I don't think there's any topic
that is used too commonly because
the way that people interpret it
is always going to be different.
So celebrate the one that you kind
of are feeling, embrace that one.
And I think sometimes the hardest thing to
tell people is, giving them the power to
do because they're like,
now I can go in so many directions.
And as you're reading,
you're going to be having to
choose [LAUGH] through different
opportunities sets, different choices.
I think this is a fun way for you to
start playing around in that area and
experimenting to find out how you decide.
So that's kind of an intended ripple
effect of this application process
which is also why I love that,
our questions are open and meaningful.
>> Yeah, that's a great point, I mean,
leaders come in all shapes and sizes too.
And we're not just admitting someone
with a specific leadership style.
People have all kinds of
leadership styles and
they can be valuable in
many different ways.
And so, yeah,
this is one of those things where in
the essay you have
the liberty to talk about.
How you make decisions,
how much you value a particular thing and
how that would impact the decisions
that you make in your life?
>> Here's a question from Sega.
So we've talked a lot about kind of the
essays, a story, how the pieces connect,
how should I balance the detail
of resume versus impact.
What types of information can I share
where that give you those levels and
bits of evidence that really
clarify that picture?
But what happens if you're not sure
what that end goal is just yet?
So the question itself, how can applicants
who don't know exactly what path they
want to take after business school.
But rather want to use business school
as an opportunity to explore and
really understand the different
pathways and options.
How do you show that effectively in
an application without appearing confused?
Any examples of how previous
applicants have done this successfully?
>> Mm-hm, that's a great question.
I think,
I don't want people to feel like they
have to have it all
figured out by any means.
In fact, even though you have
the opportunity to share some of
your aspirations and career goals,
and why Stanford would be a good fit,
we don't hold true [LAUGH] to
what you write and why Stanford.
It's an element that's important for
us to hear about
what are the things that you're
ascribing to, but we certainly.
And if you're part of
the Stanford ethos and community,
it is all about learning and keeping
an open mind, and discovering new things,
and having the support of the community
to help you think through that.
So to some extent, it should be a two year
exploration or journey for individuals.
And it doesn't have to be, you might come
in and be like, I know I want to go from x
to y and I'm pivoting or
I'm staying in the same career path.
But I see the business education
as a way to get me there.
That's great too, but I think there's
certainly some liberties here for
people to really use the two years
to think about what's next for them.
We don't often get an opportunity
to take a step back and
reflect, and that's what the MBA
program allows you to do.
If your last step in your career and
if been doing what you thought was
appropriate, this is the time in your life
where you can really think about
what that next step looks like.
So I'm looking at it just to make sure,
how can you effectively
without looking confused?
I think one thing that's important and
is if you are sharing something
that's really, let's say,
for example, you have a passion for
getting into media.
And that is where you
want to see yourself go.
If there's no evidence that you even
dabbled in that space prior to coming
to business school, we may question,
why hasn't that come up.
Whether it was tried to get involved
in some organization when you were
an undergrad or even post grad.
Or that perhaps you had an externship, and
you enabled yourself to do it in a space
where you could kind of explore that.
It is helpful to see some element
if it is a passion of yours that
you want to pursue that there's
some evidence that you've explored
a little bit about that before
getting to the business school.
I don't know, that's my thought,
I might just actually question if
I don't see enough that shows me.
>> Yeah, sometimes that kind of
exploration might be in your
essays to read.
Because not everybody might have had
the opportunity to like dabble in
the world of VC.
But what is it about venture capital
that might speak to you, right?
So even if it's in your, what matters,
or somewhere to let us know,
where does this interest come into play?
How does this fit in?
So I actually think, Sega,
you might be under estimating that
how much of a direction
you might already have.
I think exploration in and
of itself is totally valid and
a really relevant reason to
go to business school, right?
Stephanie just talked about it's
baked into the programme pretty much,
I think 70, 75% of our students do at
least one pivot in some way before.
And, There must be something
you're interested in exploring.
Maybe it's a field, maybe it is a role,
maybe it is an impact that
you're looking to make.
So even as you're thinking
about exploration and
the different options,
there are going to be ways for
you to narrow that down into something
that feels bite sized, right?
The only people or the only person you
need to convince that this is a valid
reason to go to business school is you,
it's you.
>> It's you, yes-
>> And so a couple ways for
you to maybe think through,
all right, What could that be for
me and even if it's an open-ended,
it's open-ended in that direction.
This feels very plugging
one of our other events.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But in sharing your story one,
starting your story,
I actually walk folks through a couple of
different exercises to help get
those creative juices going.
>> Yeah
>> One of the questions you might
be able to ask yourself is,
if there was anything that you could do,
no preconceived notions of what
success was like, no fear of failure,
anything that you want to do,
what would it be?
Do some brainstorming, do some free
writing, talk to people about that and
you might be surprised at how much focus
you might already have or how much
kind of dimension and interest in me you
can add to that exploration element.
So, definitely ways to do it and
you probably already know
more than you think you do.
>> Yeah, and what I do love,
that's so well said, well,
I hope that people take that to heart.
What I do love about the community
at the GSB is that if you are doing
that exploration, you're going
to be surrounded by people who
instead of telling you why it
can't be done or questioning.
They're really going to be open
up to tell me more about that and
how can I help support you and
really allowing you to dig into that and
find out if it's something
worth pursuing or not as well.
You might have a number of
different hypotheses that you test
during your two years.
>> So
we have about seven minutes remaining.
Stephanie, I think we can actually do
a lightning round of what's remaining.
So let's do that and then we can close
with any final words of advice we have.
So, would you view
candidates with 14 years,
how do you view candidates with
14 years of work experience?
>> With someone who has a lot
of experience worth sharing,
we certainly value the perspective
that you could bring to the classroom,
given the experience you've had,
and we see that as a value add in
the classroom to be able
to bring that perspective.
>> Yeah, and
it's not about how long you've worked, but
what have you done during that time?
Number of years of work experience, age,
those are not parts of our evaluation
process, it's more about what
footprints have you left behind?
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> All right, next one, any practical
suggestions on how to solve when seams
sound banal when put together, even though
the individual incidences are unique.
So how to tie things together?
I'll take this one first, Stephanie.
>> Yeah.
>> So even if, plugging another event,
yesterday sharing your story too,
writing in the application,
we did a what matters most to you and
why kind of thought exercise.
So we did a quick version there.
There is also already posted a more
extended version of that workshop that I
did earlier in the year.
So definitely check out our
Stanford GSB YouTube channel,
there are going to be
a bunch of videos there.
We're really working on building out the
number of resources that you all can use
to help guide you through this process.
We want everybody to know that,
yes you can do this,
here are tools to help you put
your best foot forward, all right.
Let's see, understanding the parts of
the application, the process is holistic.
Are there certain parts that you feel
applicants tend to overlook in terms of
importance to the broader
evaluation process?
>> No I don't think there's
a general theme, I think no.
>> Yeah, same, no general theme.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Here's a question,
nowadays it seems that it has become
fashion to mention social impact and
NGO work.
That's the goal behind pursuing an MBA.
How do we as the admissions committee
distinguish true motivation behind
students applying to the MBA program?
Okay, so that might not be so
much of a lightning round type question.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah, right?
[COUGH] Well, we hope that when
you are sharing whatever it
is that's important to you that
it is part of the application,
as I agree that everything in
here is as authentic as possible.
And so no, you do not have to fit
a [LAUGH] of having any desire for social
impact necessarily, but what is important
is that you are authentically sharing
the values that are important to you
>> Yeah, if nonprofit, if NGO,
if social impact is not what drives you,
you don't have to.
I am not looking for
someone who wants to do that necessarily.
There's another question in the Q&A box,
do I have to want to change the world?
No, that's not at all something that
we're looking at as like a necessity.
This is about,
how do you want to almost even think
about changing your life, right?
Going to business school is going to help
you look at the world through different
lenses, so changes can be small.
>> Yeah.
>> And meaningful, but that's going to
depend on you and what your priorities and
your values are.
So don't listen to the chatter,
center yourself, and
you're going to be the most effective and
compelling when you're talking about
the things that you care about.
>> Yes.
>> And here is one more question and
maybe we can close on this and
then go into advice.
How do we view failure?
I think there's might be actually a couple
different questions here about failure,
let me make sure I'm getting it properly.
Is it something you find
it hard to understand,
what experience would have been like?
What do you say, how will we advise-
>> Yeah, and someone else said,
can applicants talk about their failures-
>> Yes.
>> They have positively.
So I think it's absolutely
you can talk about a failure.
Entrepreneurs will say fail
often to succeed sooner,
so there's value in what you
learn from the failure, right?
So I think the failure itself
can feel like just that, but
it's actually what your outcome
is as a result of the failure.
Do you use that as something that
impedes you going forward that
you have the fear of not
being able to overcome?
Or has the failure itself
taught you to look at things
in a different way and
overcome those challenges?
So I think failure is
a natural part of life and
actually is a framework and
fabric of who you are as a person,
how you've grown and
that's very meaningful, and so
take those as opportunities to
convey what you've learned.
That's what I would say.
>> All right, and Stephanie people have
heard from me enough throughout the week.
Any final parting words, words of wisdom,
words of encouragement that you
can share with everybody who
have shared time with us today?
>> Sure, I mean,
[LAUGH] I think at a very high level,
there's some anxiety and fear or
concern about my gosh,
should I even apply,
the acceptance rate is so
low I couldn't possibly get in.
And I would just say that 100% sure far
way of not getting in is not to apply.
So the most encouraging advice
I can give to everyone is
just to put your foot forward.
That that is going to give you the best
opportunity for us to learn about you.
And so I encourage everyone on
the line to take that leap of faith
to believe in yourself to put
your best foot for and apply.
>> Thank you so much for
sharing this time with us.
Stephanie, thank you for
letting me pick your brains,
chit chat about a profession and
job that we love and
being able to support folks through
it is just the most amazing feeling.
So, thank you,
thank you everybody out there.
I hope to cross paths with you again soon.
Until then, stay safe.
[MUSIC]